hey yo where's my money
well give me my money all right
we're going to get into this video in a
second
today we're going to look at amp
adversarial motion priors for stylized
physics-based character control by
shiebin peng
tu ma pietrabil sergei levine and anju
kanazawa
and this paper is in the domain
of control and reinforcement learning
but it's with a little bit of a twist so
on a high level this paper
uh trains an agent a physical agent as
you can see here
to perform some sort of goal in the case
on the right it's
walking up to a target and punching the
target
but to do so in a certain style and the
style
is provided by an expert data set or a
demonstration data set
so the technique that the paper presents
mixes two things it mixes goal achieving
reinforcement learning and it also mixes
adherence to a given style
and the adherence to a given style
that's going to be the adversarial
part right here because that's learned
in an adversarial way
the mixture of the two uh at the end
looks pretty pretty cool so
the setup right here is a setup of
goal achieving and imitation learning as
we have already
um outlined and the way it works
is the following there is going to be a
task and the
task can be you have to reach a goal the
task can be you have to punch something
um you have to overcome some obstacles
and then reach a goal any anything
like this is a task so the goals are
fairly
high level and they are given obviously
by a
reward function so you place the agent
in an environment
and there is a reward function by the
way the agent here
is as we already also said is this sort
of
physical agent that um
is going to have some sort of
a 3d structure so there's going to be
joints
that it can move so there's a joint here
and one here usually
so and there's a head the agent is this
physical thing and it's in a physics
simulation and each one of these joints
it can move kind of independently
sometimes
free uh as a as a ball sometimes it's
restricted
it's modeled very much like a human
there are
other i believe other models such as a
t-rex which of course work differently
but you have this agent and
the agent is supposed to reach a goal
like somewhere over here there's a
little flag
there's a goal and the way the agent can
interact with the world
is by putting force on any of these
joints so it can move these joints in
pretty specified ways
and that constitutes the actions so the
agent will observe
the state and the state here is given
mostly by it can observe
how all the joints are currently uh the
velocity of the
of the joints or of the of the
individual parts of itself
in relation to itself so it can sort of
feel itself and it also knows in which
direction
and generally how far away the target
that it needs to reach is so that's the
observation space
the action spaces it can affect these
joints
and the reward function is often modeled
in accordance with the goal
so the reward function for walking to
some
goal might simply be you get reward if
you are closer to the goal
okay so this encourages the agent to go
over there
so we work with quite dense rewards
right here
um because i guess the fundamental
problems of reinforcement learning
aren't exactly the point here the point
here is
can you teach these things to achieve a
goal while maintaining a certain
style now this is the
the task and the environment in addition
to that you do get a data set
and the data set is demonstrations
of a certain nature so this is
not necessarily demonstrations of how to
reach the goal
it can be any sort of demonstrations
so usually when people do sort of
imitation learning or learning from
demonstrations
there is a bit there are some
requirements if you want to do
pure learning from demonstration of
course the demonstrations need to be
how to achieve the goal um and that
we don't we don't have that here in
other cases you do
need the sort of policy or the action
of whoever performed the data set we
also don't need that here
our goal is simply going to be we have
to reach the task
while while um sort of adhering to the
data set
in a way and this way we're going to
define in a second so
the data set you can imagine um i think
there is a good
demonstration down here you can imagine
the the data set to give you sort of the
style of movement
so in one data set you can have running
movements and walking movements
and in another data set you could have
these movements
that where just the these actors walk
like zombies
and the goal here is to combine
the style of the data set with reaching
the goal
okay so the combination would look like
a zombie uh walking to the goal
which adheres to the zombie walk in the
data set
and the goal in specified by the task
okay naturally you're um you're going to
model this as two different
reward signals so there's the reward
signals of
how much you reach the goal and there is
the reward signal
of how well you adhere to the style in
the data set
the reward goal right here is modeled by
classic reinforcement learning
so this is very much very very classic
um where do we have it
so you would simply train i don't even
think it's
it says here it's update g and d yada
yada
so this is a policy gradient method
reinforcement
learning which means that you do have a
policy function which takes in a state
and maybe a history
and it will give you and it will give
you an
action and with that you also train a
value function
that takes a state and will give you a
value
for that state now the value function is
purely for training the agent because
you do
you do advantage estimation with this
value function
but essentially this is a standard
policy gradient
method that you train this part this
lower part
of the this lower part of the thing on
sorry you actually train the whole thing
on this reward
um but the bottom part you can imagine
is it a reward comes from reaching a
goal
the top part gives also gives you a
reward
okay and yes i want to reiterate both of
these rewards are used to train
the policy and the value in a policy
gradient fashion
so both rewards ultimately are in this
standard
advantage estimation reinforcement
learning setting
however the top reward is calculated
differently than simply do you reach the
goal
the top reward is a measure of how close
you are in
style to the data set and that's given
by this motion prior
and the motion prior is given by
a gan by a generative adversarial
network
and i'm trying to to find the
formula here um
i think this here is the the best
description
of it though it's just a formula so
a generative adversarial model uh i'm
pretty sure you're
you're all aware uh there is a data set
right here there is a generator
right here the generator gets some
random noise as an input
it outputs a sample x from the data set
you get a sample
x prime or a mini batch and then both of
these
or the these either of these goes into
the
discriminator model and the
discriminator has to decide
for any sample is it real or is it fake
so the way this uh generative
adversarial network
uh approaches the problem of specifying
which
motions are real and which ones are not
is by
looking at transitions so the data set
here is not images or so like you're
used to in a regular game
but the data set is transitions what
does that mean
so in every situation your humanoid or
whatnot is here
and the goal is over here
and this is one state this is s
and then the agent takes an action
okay the action could be please lift one
leg
and um how does that evolve so the new
agent would be
kind of here shifting the weight a
little bit
and lifting one leg okay so this would
be
one action which would lead to a new
state s
prime so you have three quantities you
have the state you have the action
that the agent took and you have the
new state s prime now you could
parameterize
the transition either using state and
action
or state and next state the paper here
does
state and next state for the reason that
in the data set in the data set that you
get
right here you do not have the action
available
you can probably guess it but you do
have the state
and the next state this data set can
come from
anywhere it can come from human
demonstration it can come from
key frames made by a 3d artist or maybe
another agent that has already solved
the problem therefore you don't always
have the actions available
so a transition is going to be specified
by a state and a next state
and the transitions from the data set
are transitions that you observe in the
real world so these are state
next state act pairs that you observe in
the real world
and the generator the generator
essentially outputs state
next state pairs now this generator
isn't a generator in a like in a classic
adversarial network
but this here is generated
by your policy interacting with the
environment right
so here's your policy it interacts
with the environment and
the environment gives you the state and
in the next step it gives you the next
state
right so by interacting with your
environment
you do get state next state pairs
these are essentially your generated
pairs
and the discriminator is trained to
discriminate between
whether or not a transition is
from the real data set or whether it has
been
generated by your agent okay
now of course this whole system isn't
back propagatable
and that's why you do train it using
reinforcement learning so the reward
the usual back propagation signal that
you would have in a
generator right here you can't do that
that's why you simply
take the output here the loss of the
discriminator
as a reward for the um
for the policy right here so in this
case the policy
using a policy gradient is trying
to fool the discriminator into thinking
it into it thinking
that the transitions that it generates
come
from a real data set while the
discriminator at the same time is always
trained to differentiate
between the true data set and the
transitions that the policy generates
right so that gives you a reward signal
for the policy
and the other reward signal comes simply
from the environment as we've already
stated so
these two rewards are then combined with
each other
and used to train the policy the
discriminator itself as we already seen
is trained um so this thing here is
actually the discriminator this
motion prior is trained one hand from
the data set
and on the other hand uh from the
from the policy generating actions
uh and generating transitions through
the environment
all right i hope that is a bit clear
right here
so there are many components to this but
two
are important the policy which tries to
at the same time reach a goal and fool
the discriminator
those are two rewards their two rewards
are combined and the
on the other hand the discriminator
itself simply gets transitions from the
data set
and gets transitions from the policy
environment interaction
and tries to train itself to pull the
two apart
so it's a it's a classic two-player game
and
yeah that that is what you're used to
from again
all right and that's essentially it for
this thing uh here is the algorithm we
generally initialize everything there is
a
replay buffer like in a classic
reinforcement learning which stabilizes
training quite a bit i also mentioned
the value function which is used
for the advantage estimates of policy
gradient
so you for m steps you collect
trajectories
using the policy you already have then
you feed the
transitions uh to the discriminator
right here
now this here is a feature function of
the state
so you only they have special feature
functions
which make the this problem easier
there's a lot of expert knowledge going
into
how you build the features how you
represent the environment and so on
so it's not quite trivial but i don't i
don't want to go too much into that
you do calculate the style reward
according to equation seven equation
seven is simply the
discriminator uh it's not the
discriminator loss
so the discriminator loss is actually is
this thing right here
they do use a square loss for the
discriminator
instead of a classic gan
loss so the classic gan loss would be
this thing up here where it's log d
minus
log one minus d yet they use this
square loss that they found to work a
lot better or
least square loss you can see the
discriminator is trained to be
close to one if the data comes from the
real data set which is capital m here
and it's trained to be negative one when
it comes from the policy
okay so nothing stops the discriminator
from
spitting out any number like 15 or three
it's just trained in a least squares
fashion to go
to these numbers which gives you a
better gradient um
so for this for these uh continuous
control
problems often uh you have to go to
least squares
objectives because which number is being
output
is often quite important rather than
just a classification and even here
where it is actually a classification
loss right which is surprising but
cool um and then the reward
you know given a transition is
calculated as
so this is clipped at zero uh so this is
also between
zero and one as you can see here if the
discriminator
uh says one the reward is the highest
the reward is actually one
and when is the discriminator one the
discriminator is one
if it thinks that the reward sorry that
the transition comes from the real data
set
so if the policy manages
to produce a transition that the
discriminator thinks comes from the real
data set it gets
maximum reward okay and if it also
reaches the goal
it gets maximum reward from that part of
the reward signal too
so the general encouragement
that we give the policy is you should
reach the goal in a matter that's
consistent with the data set
so it should probably pick out things
that do both
right it could try to it could try to
um switch between the two modes like
okay let's do a little bit of data set
let's do a little bit of goal reaching
but it's probably better if it actually
picks things from the data set or
behaviors from the data set
that also reach the goal in a
matter consistent with the reward with
the
task reward so the algorithm just to
finish it goes on
and it says um okay so this is the style
reward
the true reward is given by a mixture a
weighted mixture between the
style and the task reward and the
weights you have to specify
and then we simply store these
this trajectory in our replay buffer and
then we use the replay buffer
to update the discriminator
and we also use the replay buffer to
update the
value function and the trajectory
according to policy gradient they point
out a few
things that are important right here to
their
algorithm one of them they find very
important is this gradient penalty
so again training can be a bit unstable
and these gradient penalties they um
are a way to stabilize this training and
they found
that simply penalizing the
norm of the gradient as it comes out of
the discriminator
is stabilizing the training right here
so this is one thing they've they helped
uh they
this is one thing that they claim is
helping
them a lot to actually converge and
this tells you a little bit that it's
still quite quite finicky they talk a
lot about
um the representation of the actions
right here
the policy here in network architecture
the policy
and value and and discriminator
functions
they are very simple multi-layer
perceptron
um so you can see like the
mean the mean of the policy function
is specified by a fully connected
network with two hidden layers
consisting of
and two uh five hundred and twelve relu
relu consistently relu
okay um i guess that's a fully connected
layer with a relu
non-linearity followed by a linear
output so the
networks aren't super complicated right
here what's more complicated is the
training procedure the
loss the regularization constants
and the reward engineering so there is a
lot of reward engineering happening
right here and that's
what you find in the appendix so the
reward for example um for
going and punching something is is
threefold so
if you are far away it's one reward if
you're
close it's a different reward and if
that target has been hit
it's a different reward right i guess
the top line
makes sense but the others are sort of
reward
shaping the behavior you want so you
want the
um the agent to kind of approach the
target fast but then kind of slow down
and also you know if you look at
something like
dribbling where there's a ball involved
there is a lot of reward shaping going
on
even in uh in target location
there is a lot of reward shaping going
on where you
sort of encourage the agent to have
certain velocities and so on
so um this is important because
of the experimental results that they
show and that's where we go back to the
video where's the video
right here so keep in mind um
their point is you're able to reach a
goal in the style of the data set
so this is the simplest task they have
it's called
target heading and the goal is simply to
walk or to go
in a given direction at a certain speed
okay
and um the example clips
they have are displayed on the right so
the example clips
are of someone walking and of someone
running yet there is not really a
transition in the data set
from walking to running and the
the the agent learns to this transition
by itself so their point is always look
we have kind of simple things in the
data set we have the individual parts
in the data set that the agent should do
but we never have the
combination of all the things and to
kind of stitch these parts together
that's the powerful thing
about this method which is pretty cool
so here
you can see at the top right there is a
target
speed and all of these three agents are
trained agents
and the um in the same manner right
and they're all told to reach that given
target speed
however the agent on the left only has
been provided with a data set
of people just walking the date the
agent in the middle the same but it it
has only received a data set of just
uh agents running so no walking and
on the right this agent has received a
data set
of agents walking and running so you can
see
that as the target speed changes
the like if it's fast the walker is not
able to keep up when it's slow
the runner is not able to slow down
however the
agent that has the full data set
available can
not only match the speed and change its
style according to the speed
it can it also learns the transitions
from one to the other
and this these transitions are not in
the data set itself
okay so the cool part about this method
is it can sort of
stitch together the appropriate
behaviors from the data set
uh even if you don't provide these
specifically to solve the task
um the yeah this is the the t-rex i
think this is just to show that you
don't have use motion capture
but you can use it you can learn
from a provided data set of keyframe
animation
and you can also see the there is
nothing in the data set about reaching a
goal
there's just kind of demonstrations of
the t-rex walking
and the method is able to adapt this
walking style
uh in concordance with reaching a goal
so you can see that the turning is much
like
the turning in the example clips whereas
if you've ever seen
things like this without um without
the the examples uh these
policies that these things come up with
are quite
weird so here is a failure case
and so the difference between this
method and
other methods is other methods um such
as this motion tracking in the middle
what they try to do is they try to match
a given behavior from the data set as
closely as possible
um so this it's called motion tracking
now
there is a some sophistication to it
more than i'm
saying right here but essentially you
have a front flip
on the left and then the motion tracking
algorithm tries to learn a policy
such that the um the behavior is
followed as closely as possible
now again this is really good when you
have the exact demonstration available
from what you want to do it's not so
good if
you if what you have available as
demonstrations
is not isn't really what you want to do
is just
sort of some demonstrations but there
are failure cases of course if you want
to copy exactly
so if you want to do a front flip and by
the way the reward function here
is how closely you match
the motion from the reference motion
so that's the reward function however
motion tracking does more than that
motion tracking really tries to track
the motion itself
while this method here would only get
the reward of tracking the motion
and you can see it doesn't manage to
to actually learn um
it more like doesn't try it tries to not
fail it so it reaches the same end
position and that's sort of
good enough for it so there is a
yeah there is a trade-off right here
it's probably also given by how much you
weigh the different components
so here you have a data set of uh agents
walking
and agents waving and then
uh what you want to do is you want to
have
a agent that walks in a direction while
they
wave the arm or why they they lift the
arm or something
so at the left you can see if you only
have a data set
if you only have a data set of the
waving
agents it's really struggling moving
forward right that the walking it learns
it has no demonstration of walking so
that's a struggle
if you only have the walking
demonstration in the middle then
it doesn't really track
the arm movement where it should even
though there is a reward
for it right only yeah on the right i
mean this is
somewhat somewhat but it is kind of able
to um
to interpolate so if you if you want to
check out this video there is another
one that actually explains the paper
in a in a short form this is from uh
from siggraph
go check it out they do have more
sophisticated behaviors so on the bottom
here you can for example see
the obstacle run
leap and roll so the data set contains
demonstrations from
all of those things but not the things
in conjunction
with each other in
this here at least what they describe in
the text in this
this right here what they have in the
data set
is demonstrations of walking and
demonstrations of
getting up from the ground and
whenever so the agent learns that
whenever it
falls over right here that it can get up
faster if it kind of does this
rolling motion right here so this was
nowhere in the data set
but because the agent wants to
go to a get up state both because that
will
go it that will make it go towards a
goal
and also because that matches behavior
in the data set
it will learn this rolling motion as it
falls down
in order to get up again so that is
that's pretty cool
also in this strike and punch example
the data set apparently only contains uh
agents walking or agents punching
it never contains agents walking and
then
punching so the transition that you saw
at the beginning
is a learned uh behavior
that wasn't in the data set so that's
i think it's a it's a pretty cool
application
of and the combination of two things of
adversarial learning
and of um of learning sorry
uh not from demonstration because that's
that we're serial learning of learning
to reach a goal
and it's a good yeah it's a good
demonstration of how you can combine the
two they have a lot of ablations
where they sort of show that the impact
of the data set makes a big difference i
mean you've seen this
in the demonstrations but also here you
can see that again in a graphical form
so the locomotion data set contains both
demonstrations of walking
and running while the walk or the run
data set only contains demonstrations of
either
and the here is the target speed versus
the average speed that the agent
does now if you only have a walking data
set
the agent no matter the target speed the
agent will always kind of stick
to walking and if you have the running
data set
it can run faster up here but if you
want it to slow down it can't really run
slower than you require uh only when
the data set contains both things uh
can it transition between the two and
actually match the
running or walking so
what do we think of this um my opinion
is it's probably it's very cool and
it is a it's a good way of sort of
bringing demonstrations into the picture
without manually like tracking the
demonstrations or copying exactly so you
just give
some suggestions to the algorithm of
what it
could do and you do that in form of a
data set
which is something that i you know
like because it's not as invasive as
telling the agent you know you need to
match the joint movements and so on
of the of the demonstration this enables
demonstrations to come in that are of a
much broader range
not necessarily reach the goal not
necessarily even have a goal in mind
so that's cool on the other hand i think
it's
pretty finicky because you have to
strike the trade-off parameter between
the two rewards
quite cleanly or clearly for your goal
because we've already seen right at some
point
the agent won't reach the goal anymore
if
if this reward here if the reward of the
style is too high we already saw this if
you have a data set of just
running the agent will simply neglect
the goal it won't
go slower than you know the
kind of the slowest run or demonstration
or a little bit slower than that
it just won't change its policy because
it needs to match
the data set and the this balance seems
to be
quite quite a important hyper parameter
and that also makes the provided data
set here quite an important
thing to to have available
so which data set you provide is also
quite
important and lastly the tasks
themselves
or the reward of the goal
directed task nature or in this paper
extremely engineered and that's what i
want to come back here
lastly too so what they tout for example
in this um walk and punch thing
they they say oh when the agent is far
away
it runs towards the target but if it's
close
it only it slows down and then when it's
really close
it punches the target and it sort of
learns
to combine these different skills but
and which is cool
right because the transition wasn't in
the data set but a big part of
it combining these skills is because
in the reward you make the reward
different
whether the agent is far away or
whether it's near you can see that right
here so
these things are reward shaped to a high
degree
to encourage these kinds of transitions
to happen
which i think is not really practical
in a lot of settings so
it's still to be seen how much this is
of
of practical value in other
reinforcement learning tasks
where you don't have that available and
also in other reinforcement learning
tasks
where maybe the reward is more sparse
and how that affects this thing because
essentially if the reward
is much more sparse and irregular
now you have a problem because now the
style signal
is much more prominent and that's not
necessarily solved by simply
re-weighing the style signal so i'm
excited to see
what comes out of this line of work next
it's a pretty cool line as i already
said it's a good application
of gans in a different field than images
and with that let me know what you think
in the comments
i'll see you next time bye